our podcasts on our new c-span now app
[Music]
washington journal continues
andrew yang is joining us he's the
author of forward notes on the future of
our democracy he ran for the presidency
in 2020 and also with other decisions
being made this week included leaving
the democratic party mr yang thanks for
joining us this morning
thanks for having me it's great to be
here uh as far as the decision to leave
the party itself what at what moment
exactly did you know it was time to
leave
well i left because of the polarization
that unfortunately threatens to tear our
country apart uh i like c-span in part
because you really do
just present unfiltered
politics and news
but if you look around right now we have
these media institutions that are
actually inflaming
tensions and polarization in different
ways and i thought that there was a way
and a need a pressing need to help bring
the temperature of our
country down
and that's why i left the democratic
party to become an independent and start
the forward party which will be this
unifying popular movement to change the
incentives of our political leaders to
actually respond to the reasonable among
us and not the extremes on either side
because right now if you look at the
numbers and i'm a math guy independents
outnumber registered democrats and
independents almost uh on and sorry
registered democrats and republicans uh
almost two to one in some surveys and
yet we know that that point of view is
often getting lost
what
what part of being part of a major party
was inflaming to you as particularly
being part of the democratic party
oh
i mean i didn't feel particularly
inflamed i suppose
i was a democrat for 26 years uh you
know ever since um i could register to
vote but
right now
uh
we we're seeing a dysfunctional system
where we're not able to get anything
done on either side and i think people
who are watching this at home can relate
to that
and if you're a reasonable person
watching at home you're scratching your
head being like why is it that our
leaders seem so unreasonable relative to
really anyone else you can find
and the answer is that those are the
incentives of our system where right now
if you become an elected representative
you don't answer to
51 of the population much as we'd like
to pretend otherwise so who do you
answer to you answer to the 10 to 20
percent
of the most partisan voters who will
vote either democratic or republican in
your district 83
of districts are safe seats uh so
they're either going to be very blue or
very red
right now and i can sense even from the
people who are calling in
the approval rate for congress
nationally is only 28
people don't love what's going on or not
going on
but the reelection rate for individual
members is 92
people are going to win election over
and over again in part because again
they are catering to the base on either
side and then when they come together
they can't get anything done so that's
the system as it's currently set up
we're all fed up by it we're all
frustrated and this is the the biggest
thing is that we're being sold a bill of
goods that is actually intended to work
when it's actually not designed to work
and so what i want to do is actually get
into the guts of the real problems that
i talk about in my book
and that isn't just a democratic problem
or republican problem it's a system-wide
problem and so that's why i had to leave
the democratic party to try and get this
work done as far as a real problem as
you see if that existed elsewhere how
would you identify that and how does the
forward party
remedy that
well in a past life i ran a business uh
and i also have been an entrepreneur
and one of the things you learn
is that people respond to incentives
that if you reward them they're going in
a certain direction that's generally
where they'll go
so what are the political incentives
right now
it's to get up and make very very
uh
ideological or inflammatory arguments
that some people will love and the
people that love those arguments will
send you money will vote you back in
again uh in very very partisan primaries
and so what we have to do is have to
change the incentives we have to make it
so wait instead of just listening over
here and getting money from over here
over here
we want you to listen to all of us
and maybe even uh you know
if we were to really go far maybe uh
there's even a way where your financial
incentives are tied to how you're doing
relative to the entire population now
this sounds very dramatic it sounds
almost too good to be true but it's
entirely achievable
and the way we get there is by getting
rid of closed party primaries which
you're allowed to do at the state level
everything is determined at the state
level and shift to open primaries
and rank choice voting instead so open
primaries is just it's not a closed
party primary anyone can vote i think
that's very straightforward and then you
need a process so that you don't have
any spoilers uh and if there were let's
say two democrats and one republican the
republican doesn't automatically win
and so you implement a process where
voters can rank their choices so there's
no spoiler effect if you do these two
things all of a sudden our legislators
would become more productive and
reasonable overnight
and we can do this via valid initiatives
around the country we we can't wait for
congress to get attacked together
because we know that will never work so
what we have to do is go
to the to the uh the communities around
the country that are fed up which is all
of us and say let's change the process
let's make the incentives work for us
uh you give an example i think in other
interviews and writings about what
happened through that process to senator
lisa murkowski of alaska
there's a state that's already made this
change and that is alaska where now all
alaskans have a say in who their
representatives are
and what this means for senator
murkowski
is that she can exercise her independent
judgment uh and then take her decisions
to the entire
state
instead of having to go through
a
partisan primary where only 10 to 20 of
people will participate and a lot of the
people watching this at home know
exactly what i'm talking about where if
you are in the minority party in 83 of
the districts around the country you
know you don't have any meaningful say
you know by the time it gets to you in
the general it's over
and so that's something that we can
change and alaska's already made this
change just because a lot of alaskans
got together and said this is better
our guest with us for the hour up until
10 o'clock if you want to ask him
questions about the party his book and
other related matters 202 748 8001 for
republicans 202 748 8 000 for democrats
independence 202-748-8002
you can text us thoughts at 202-748-8003
mr yang your decision to leave the
democratic party how much was that was
influenced by your run for the
presidency in your run for mayor of new
york
i met a lot of wonderful people uh on my
campaigns made some really deep
friendships and connections uh and the
thing i believe and i think most people
watching this at home will agree there
are good people in every political party
there is no party that has a monopoly on
goodness so
i had
many tremendous relationships and it was
very difficult to
uh even change my voter registration
given that again i'd been a democrat for
decades but it felt like the right thing
to do if we're going to really pull our
country together
uh and see to it that people sense that
people of different political alignments
aren't your enemy we're all americans
uh you know we love our fellow americans
friends and family will vote for the
other side and we still have to come
together
afterwards and have dinner together
you write in your book more than 60
percent of americans say that both
political parties are out of touch while
57
say there's a need for a major third
party but the structural forces make it
nearly impossible you can't win races
you don't have a capital structure
financing you the media will marginalize
attack and ignore you partisans will say
that you are empowering their opponents
whom they will characterize as a toxic
threat to win you will lose friends who
occupy every position of power in the
nation on top of that it's nearly
impossible to start a viable third party
in the united states that's what you
write in the book and yet you decide to
go ahead and start one uh take it from
there
so immediately thereafter
in the book i talk about how at this
point 57 of americans want a third party
uh and there's no time like the
president to start solving this kind of
problem particularly if you have a
candidate like myself
who
i'm happy to say raised tens of millions
of dollars for my presidential run
and i believe
i can speak to people of any
party and so that
is the catalyst for what i hope is a
popular movement the forward party that
registered democrats registered
republicans and independents are all
welcome to join because we can sense
that our country's not working right now
if you're watching this at home you're
watching because you feel a
responsibility to our great country but
also i sense that most of you probably
are feeling some misgivings and some
despair
like most reasonable americans would
look up and be like huh like this is not
functioning very well and i'm here to
tell you that it's not functioning very
well because it's designed to fail um
and
you know it's a nasty system when if
everyone acts rationally we're all going
to lose at an epic scale so when you ask
why is now the time
for a third party movement to succeed
it's because we have record high
literally civil war levels of
polarization
uh and we need a solution and if
millions of us can come together and
provide this solution
then we'll all feel much much better
about the future of our country as far
as the party itself the forward party is
this a vehicle for a future presidential
run is it a vehicle to run other people
is it or just a vehicle to make these
changes that you advocate for
the number one change that we need to
make that would unlock our
leaders to actually do the jobs that we
hope they'll do is open primaries and
rank choice voting around the country we
will support candidates that advocate
for those changes
but we need to be focused right now on
the upcoming races in 2022 uh because
there's a lot of good that can be done
uh from alicia in columbia maryland
independent line you're up first with
our guest andrew yang the author
i love the independent line
our forward notes on the future of our
democracy alicia go ahead you're on
good morning pedro and
mr young is it
yes
and good morning america
listen uh
if you get some of those folks that have
been in there for so many years
they've become very bossy and if you
know who i mean
uh
what do you think about term limits
would you please comment on that
and i am an independent so i
fully support you
thank you thank you alicia that means
the world to me
uh we need term limits in congress and
75 percent of americans agree with that
you shouldn't be going to washington to
spend the rest of your life
you know like it should be a tour of
duty you get things done and then you
come home uh so if that's common sense
and we all know it why can't we have
term limits in this country the forward
party is pro term limits on members of
congress uh they should head to dc
do our work and then come home and not
see dc as their their new ultimate
destination if you agree with that
forwardparty.com but it's common sense
you know and it's a sign of the
corruption in our system that something
so obvious has not been done
from hopewell junction new york
democrats line eric hello
oh good morning to both of you and uh
and uh props to brian lamb for this
amazing forum that is really in full
blossom i think uh andrew you're a
numbers guy uh i'm really not i'm sort
of a one note numbers guy i guess you
could say i've been uh i've called him
before about this i've been for seven
and a half years now i've been taking
the personal poll i call it and i asked
people when i find them alone
when i was really hot i'd do four or
five a day you're a numbers guy you
multiply that out by seven years and
that's that's a lot of people uh
thousands and thousands of people my
criteria is when i find them alone i ask
them so
anyway my results were eighty-five
percent almost people were nice amazing
then i came up with a second question
what do you think other people think
uh about the first question and that
really made it very complex and
interesting
so i had nobody at an individual basis
was mean to me or nasty to me they
engaged me which i think was a total big
positive because it's unusual in this
hooked up age when everybody has a
computer in their pocket no incidental
conversation necessary um you know
for somebody to confront them with these
kinds of inane on the surface you know
sort of provocative question getting out
of their skin i mean you do it all the
time uh and and i i i'm amazed at your
abilities uh and and you following your
star and saying that the polemics in
both sides are out of control and it
just ties into mrs haugen's uh testimony
yesterday about who's playing us and and
and
to the point of no return eric thank you
very much
oh i want to speak to that because it
actually comes up at length in my book
and and it's one reason why i talk about
c-span so favorably we are being
manipulated no so you have these
political incentives that are driven to
manipulate us through alarmist uh
fundraising messages and everything like
you know please send me money or the
world's going to come to an end we've
all gotten the messages
and then you have media organizations
c-span accepted where they have
identified an audience that likes a
certain status or a message they're
going to give them more and then that
ends up heightening their both
inflammation and polarization and then
you hit the nail on the head that social
media is pouring fuel on the whole
thing social media terrible
for
any semblance of rational discourse
negativity and mistruth
spread six times more quickly on social
media
so in that environment how the heck are
you going to be able to to come together
again love c-span for this reason and i
sense that you all are watching and
calling into c-span because you see it
as something of an antidote it's free of
a lot of these market pressures i'm
describing uh and we should be doing
much more for local journalism which by
the way tends to be much less political
uh you know if you miss your local paper
like let's bring it back 2000 local
papers have gone out of out of business
it's a crime
like how can you have a thriving
democracy if there's there's no one
covering news in your town like how the
heck are you gonna even know what's
going on or who to vote for so that
there's some obvious problems that are
being driven by by
this uh hyper capitalism that we're in
the midst of uh and it's shredding any
chance of
being able to come together and have
rational conversations so love c-span
keep it up um but i i understand what
you're saying we are being manipulated
we're being set up and that's what we
have to stop together you mentioned
facebook specifically in your book you
write this the more data sets a company
has the more valuable each of them is
facebook and the ads network includes
many other apps and websites you don't
even be on the facebook app itself to be
participating in the harvesting of your
data we are not the client or the end
user anymore we are the product instead
of having things sold to us we are being
sold to those who have with the means to
buy access to every detail of our
behavior and a financial interest to
shape what we do next in light of what
you wrote there what did you think about
that testimony on capitol hill from that
whistleblower uh francis haugen
i was entirely unsurprised by everything
that francis howard said and the fact is
that there are people like me that know
this stuff's going on you know the only
people who don't know this stuff going
on washington dc truly you know you
could like line up most adults uh
certainly anyone who's related to the
tech industry at all and they would say
oh yeah like you know there are noxious
effects of this facebook for sure knows
facebook for sure is dissembling about
what those effects are why because
they're a trillion dollar franchise and
they're not going to shoot themselves in
the foot which again should surprise
absolutely nobody so this is a product
of the fact that our leaders in
washington are just decades behind the
curve decades and you know one reason
why they're decades behind the curve
is because they've been in dc for too
long to alicia's original question we
need term limits we need people rotating
in and out and then you'd have people
who might have uh used facebook natively
themselves who are like oh yeah this is
a problem
is there a forward party approach then
it comes to social media not only how
you use it for your party itself but how
changes should be made
well we have a platform around data
rights which is that our data right now
is getting sold and resold for by the
way hundreds of billions of dollars are
you seeing any of that money no you're
not you know who's seeing it all mark
zuckerberg and facebook so
it's uh something of like a human rights
issue where like if our data is getting
sold and resold and we're getting
manipulated don't you want to stop that
so we should be passing laws around our
own data rights and if we decide to
share it with a tech company for our own
convenience then we need to know what's
going on there needs to be
an independent guardian for us that's
not the tech company itself and if
there's any money to be made to be made
we should be getting some of that money
i think those are very straightforward
rules
from don st joseph missouri independent
line
hello uh
i i see the
big problem in elections is
the money there's there's no way a lower
class person can compete
you have to be a millionaire practically
or have access to millions of dollars to
even run right for any
a long seat
what we need to do away with that by
[Music]
having the states
have a election
uh mechanism a website where all the
information that the candidates have
uh and they're to be required to be on
the ballots they'd have to
fill in the forms like um
saying what their positions are
uh right now the the
people all they can rely on is a
30-second tv commercial and that's why
we're getting such bad candidates
and uh i don't think third parties would
be uh
an answer and i don't like the rank
choice
uh voting that just had some
confusion to the long drawn-out process
but
we should just have like a
conservative party
and then a
liberal party
and all the party other groups and
parties would have to go into one of
those and be on the ballot okay caller
thank you don
well i i want to speak to the point
about money and politics and he is of
course correct uh the average
congressional campaign now costs
over one and a half million dollars
senate campaign 10 million dollars so
who can get that kind of money people
who are very very plugged into high
level networks may be wealthy themselves
so how do you change that public
financing of elections would be
the ideal solution and what i propose
is that every american gets a hundred
dollars of democracy dollars you can
give to anyone you want so if you get 10
000 people together and that's a million
bucks and then all of a sudden you're
competitive right now it's very very
difficult to get any normal person to
donate to a political campaign because
who the heck has that kind of money so
if you just gave people democracy
dollars it would be a huge step up but
you do have leaders who all look and
sound the same because they all come
from the same financial backgrounds
east point kentucky republican line
robert hello
hello
i
just got a comment
with mr yang there
well a couple comments
one the first one is there's too much
corruption in politics there's no
investigations into
corruptions that they
seemingly be into
but the other
uh
comment i got
is his idea on
uh
primaries
in the situation like he talks about
their supports
in an area where say a democrat gets
elected year after year after year
they can wreck uh
when somebody on a republican or
independent party has a better idea
of what to do and run the government
more honestly and
and
might be able to get elected
if they run on their party
they can the opposite party can cross
lines in the primary and get him
completely out of the situation
and that that's changing our election
uh
process that uh for the bad in my
opinion thank you
oh thank you and you're right the the
right now the party designation is
distorting everything because people are
just making strategic decisions based
upon how they're going to get elected
you know you have a lot of people just
choosing which party to run under based
upon which party is going to help them
win
and not which party they might actually
genuinely line up with which is why i
think open primaries would help because
then you can just say what you think and
then people who want to support you and
you don't have to put a d and or an r
next to your name in order to to to
have a chance to win um to the question
about corruption of course corruption is
rampant in politics right now we're
spending literally billions of dollars
influencing these people they all go to
washington uh and then they come back
somehow really wealthy
you know and you're like wait a minute
like your salary is not that high like
how is it that you've somehow made
millions of dollars during this time um
so that the that's one reason why again
you need term limits um so that people
can't go and just uh hover there and
enrich themselves in various ways and
it's all a club at this point i mean if
you were in this club and then someone
screws up like do you drum them out or
you probably just cover it up i mean
there's just a lot and it's it's
unfortunate that that's what's happening
right now but we all know what is
happening uh mr yang even as you talk to
us here in washington d.c there's
current debates between the both sides
over the debt level there's current
debates over passing the president's
agenda what's a forward party way of
dealing with these competing ideas and
coming up with a solution to go forward
that makes the best of both ideas
um so the forward party
uh principles in many ways are on full
display right now in washington where
you have these polarized sides and then
you have two senators in the middle who
are essentially controlling the entire
agenda
and that's a function of just how
broken up that the system is so the goal
with the forward party is to make both
sides more prone to actually
talking to each other and compromising
by making it so that frankly you're
responsible to voters of every uh
political party when you go for
re-election
and then maybe we even get a few people
elected through the forward party that
represent this reasonable middle that
end up being a bridge
um what's funny is people talk to me
about the forward party and the rest of
it we're going to support local
candidates it's going to be great we're
going to be supporting open primaries um
but if you win even a few races
uh you can actually do a lot of good
bringing sides together like you don't
need to win
you know in in this senate example you
don't need to to win 50 races like if
you were to win one or two races uh then
it could be a game changer for the
entire country would you go as far as
changing rules in order to get agendas
done such as the filibuster
i will say i i looked in the
constitution and there's nothing about
the filibuster i also looked in the
constitution and by the way that there's
nothing about political parties it turns
out that that the founding fathers were
not big fans of political parties they
thought that uh they would lead to
factionalism and polarization which by
the way they were right
if they were to have political parties
they wouldn't want many many more than
two
um the the
current situation is something of a
worst nightmare for our founding fathers
um and our founding fathers when they
wrote up the senate they did not include
a filibuster uh and you know you have to
ask why uh from new jersey and chester
new jersey lynette democrats line you're
on with andrew yang hello
good morning c-span long-time listener
first time caller um yes i'd like to
know
what mr yang thinks of the job that
senator sanders is doing
um i personally think he's the epitome
of a true public servant and i'm just
curious
as to what mr yang thinks thank you
wow first time caller you called on
behalf of uh of that question which i
love by the way
uh i supported bernie sanders in the
2016 primary um meeting him on the trail
when i ran for president was a privilege
when he said something nice about me
and to me like i i felt extraordinarily
proud like i've been blessed by by my uh
uncle or something along those lines um
so i'm a huge believer in bernie because
he is not corrupt in the least he's like
a pure
messenger a pure public servant he has a
vision for the country i agree with much
of his vision uh and he's just fighting
like mad until the day he dies so you
have to love and appreciate that a
viewer off of twitter uh don suddrath
asks you a question mr yang saying
reasonable reasonable people understand
your position on becoming an independent
however pulling voters especially young
democrats away to a new party opens the
door to the cult of personality and the
republican party and the wealthy how can
your decision help
well so that this is a
reaction that you get a lot from a
particular side let's call it democrats
which is that if you do anything
independent then it's going to hurt
democrats
but if you look at the numbers
there's a higher
desire for a third party or an
independent party among republicans than
there is among democrats so if you were
to actually draw it out you're more
likely to have voters from every
alignment or even from uh from the
republican party than you are democrats
and when i ran for president as a
democratic candidate
42 percent of my supporters then
in a democratic primary
weren't sure they were going to support
the democratic nominee
if it weren't me
so i have a record of appealing to
people of every alignment
and structurally
you're more likely to draw in
independence and republicans than you
are democrats as far as your run for the
presidency you wrote a recent op-ed
about what that did for you internally
as far as processing the day in and day
out of the campaign can you uh talk a
little bit about that that impact on you
i called it a reality tv show on the
debate stage pedro and i wanted to say
in my book which if you ever wonder what
it's really like to run for president uh
do buy this book because i talk about it
at length uh but the the act of running
for president is that you have makeup on
your face and you're shooting tv ads and
you're surrounded by staff all the time
uh who are ferrying you from event to
event and everywhere you go you're
giving a speech or giving a talk uh and
it messes with your brain you know it it
makes you into less of a normal person
that's for sure but uh over time it
makes you less empathetic
again this is one reason why we need
term limits
because if you're in this vortex of
attention and money
uh it deranges you and there have been
studies that show that your brain wiring
actually changes the longer you have
power
um and i didn't have you know quote
unquote power for for very long
i was a center of attention
for a particular period of time and even
that was
enough to
influence the way you interact with the
world so i i talk about the reality of
running for president as like it's not
really an act of leadership the way that
it should be i mean we talk about
leaders i don't see getting in front of
a tv camera and opining as an act of
leadership necessarily you know what i
mean like leadership is something that
you do
quietly and interpersonally and you care
about the folks that are working on your
behalf and that's not what politics
looks like today really and then you
wonder why people seem so broken and
corrupt our process actually will make
even reasonable people
less
less reasonable over time in fact and
from the book you write in part you
spend time with dozens of people whose
schedules and actions revolve around you
everyone asks what you think you
function on appearance appearance
becomes your role empathy becomes
optional or even unhelpful leadership
becomes the appearance of leadership
yeah we we have a bunch of people who
are literally
um
just trying to simulate leadership
[Laughter]
because that's the way our process is uh
and it's not great i know i mean think
about all the phenomenal people and you
watching this or you know probably
qualify i'm gonna say something dramatic
but i think if you're just to line up a
bunch of americans of any background
they would come to decisions that would
probably do
better
than our elected representatives right
now you know and it's in part because
uh in order to become an elected
representative now you need to have a
certain kind of personality uh you'd be
much more likely to have a certain kind
of financial background
[Laughter]
and
i'm
natively an introverted guy i was like a
nerdy little asian kid growing up all i
wanted to do was read books um and so
running for office was a very
uh
unusual thing
um but in a way i i want to speak for
the introverts among us
who suspect that there might be
something wrong
uh with the folks who do this for a
living um and say there might be ways we
could tweak the process so that you get
different kind of people in the door and
also
you don't have people's worst tendencies
get elevated over time let's hear from
john he's in oxen hill maryland
independent line
good morning c-span going to pedro mr
yang
uh i love him
hey
i wanted to
hear your thoughts on instead of
creating a new party
um because you start a new party you end
up having some of the same
issues um you know everyone's with a
party until that party is against you
know something they personally are
not in agreeance with and then you know
they're stuck with the party but instead
of starting a new party
what are your thoughts on
an alliance
of um
congressmen that
will
agree to
disband the party
um
system altogether
so you know you you banned
allegiance between
um
in in incumbent uh congressmen that you
know once they are elected in office
um they'll agree to disband the party
system and
just have
no parties because you know the system
where and now
people just vote up and down party lines
there's no reason
and even uh
you know
campaigning on on policies because
people are just going to vote on party
lines
that's my comment okay john
this is a this is a fun and fascinating
argument i like it
first the forward parties principles are
intentionally very very broad uh you
know one of them is grace intolerance
which is that again we love our fellow
americans we're not out to villainize
anyone
what we're upset about is a system that
is manipulating us and turning us
against each other um so we're not
taking stances on like a uh you know
dozens of issues like we're
trying to focus on the main problem
which is the structure itself
now if a bunch of members of congress
were to come together and say hey let's
get rid of our party or whatnot i would
uh i would love that but one of the
realities you see in governance is that
you probably need
at least
some kind of teams
because you know if you have a body of
435 people and there are no organizing
groups then it's it's very difficult to
operate so if you look around the world
uh they have systems where they often
have more than two parties i'm gonna
suggest that two is a very sub-optimal
number of parties
where because of two think about it two
use like class class class and then
you're like oh what's going on like that
that's the situation where it so if you
look at some place like the uk it has
five parties you look at a place like
uh sweden has eight um
and i'm gonna suggest that that would be
superior to our current system because
then instead of just two sides banging
against each other all the time you'd
have a
set of coalitions where i agree with you
on this so let's work together i don't
agree with you on this i want to work
with these people on this other thing
you probably need some parties to help
organize activities i think you just
have many many more than two
what's the ideal number i don't know i
think it should be an odd number
does this uh
you know like uh help help make um
tie breakers uh more feasible um but i
love what you're arguing and if members
of congress were to stand up and say
let's have term limits that would be
great if they were to stand up and say
look this duopoly is not the way to go
that would also be phenomenal our guest
andrew yang he's the author of forward
notes on the future of our democracy
with us until 10 o'clock mr yang what is
venture for america
venture for america is a non-profit
that helps train young entrepreneurs to
create jobs in cities around the country
many of them in the midwest and the
south i could use a boost i started
venture for america in 2011
after i had some success
and
i thought about how hard it was to
become an entrepreneur it's ridiculously
hard it's too hard
and so i thought well we need more
entrepreneurs and we need more of them
in places like detroit and birmingham
um and baltimore and so i spent a number
of years uh starting and running that
organization i'm proud to say it's now
created thousands of jobs around the
country um i was honored by the obama
administration twice for my activities
and uh it was during that time that i
traveled the midwest and the south and i
grew to realize that our economy was
being transformed by automation and we
we eliminated millions of manufacturing
jobs uh through a combination of
globalization and automation and that's
when many of you probably met me was
when i decided to run for president on
universal basic income in response to
the technological decimation of american
jobs um but i learned that through my
activities at venture for america over
six and a half years running a
non-profit organization that helped
train young entrepreneurs
uh this is andrew yang this is daniel
elizabeth pennsylvania democrats line
hello
can you hear me yep you're on
no thank you america can
yes um
i um
i i believe you have a platform
um and i was wondering if uh
your platform includes uh the
elimination of um
education by zip code
and uh if i could just say that my son
went i live in a rural community my son
um had his history education was five
years on the civil war
and um and one other thing it
would be possible because i live in a
rural community and i see a lot of
things here
um
if there is such a thing as
affirmative action for the so-called of
deplorables
thank you
thanks there are massive inequities in
our education system because of the way
it's it's built around property taxes
and zip codes as you're describing
i i do think one of the
uh great imbalances is that we are
overlooking rural communities
uh and operating as if um
really uh that um people only people of
certain background are overcoming
various struggles i mean that the fact
is poverty is rampant in rural
communities around the country and if
someone is seeking an education or other
uh ladder
we should be very much considering them
in the same light
tony from santa fe new mexico hello
independent line
tony in new mexico good morning yes
you're on go ahead
good morning
uh i don't really believe term limits
uh is really the solution the solution
for me is
the nullification
of citizens united or corporations
united
where
because i'm a john adams independent
i believe
his quote uh there's nothing to be
dreaded more than a two-party system two
parties acting in concerted effort in
opposition to each other in other words
they've been playing us all
out
isn't it
that
uh
independents
outnumber
both the democratic and republican party
true so uh that's true
we really need to get rid of citizens
united or the supreme court justices for
me that committed treason against and
usurped our constitution
and placing profit over humanity thanks
tony
i i 100 agree that we should overturn
citizens united and i say that in my
book
but i also think the problems pre-date
citizens united and that if you were to
be able to over turn citizens united
which by the way would be very difficult
in our current structures uh that the
money would find other ways in
uh even if they could just couldn't do
it directly
as citizens united enabled so money's
been dominating politics for decades uh
citizens united is not that
you know old a decision so
we we should be thinking about
overturning citizens united for sure but
we shouldn't think that our problems
will all be solved by it and you are
completely correct that independents
outnumber democrats and republicans uh
and i think that independents should get
together i think that reform-minded
democrats and republicans should get
together that's why i've started the
forward party
i hope that you will all check it out at
forwardparty.com and consider
helping move the country forward
literally because it needs it we are
being played we're being manipulated
to tony's point uh mr yang you had
mentioned your idea of universal basic
income and how you talked about that in
the campaign
as a concept is it playing out in
reality though particularly in cities
and states and especially what we saw
for stimulus pay events being delivered
to americans plus child care tax credits
now is it a concept that could work now
and it's being tested
one of the very best things that's going
on right now in our country is the child
tax credit if you were watching this
and you got a 300 check for your child
or your grand
uh your grandchild child's uh you know
parents got it i guess that would be
your kids
if a family ever got this 300 check uh
over this last couple of months and
we're like oh wow this is great
um we should keep that forever and 448
economists just signed a letter saying
we should keep it forever it has made
people less hungry it has got school
supplies
it's got
people in better position to actually
learn and spend time
with their families in the way that they
want
so the positive effects are very very
clear and
everyone now who's looked at the data
says we should include we should have
the child tax credit go on
um uh indefinitely and i'm thrilled that
my campaign might have played a role in
augmenting the thought that if we send
people
some money
um they'll
do something positive with it
particularly where their families could
start
here's mary mary's in kentucky
republican line for andrew yang go ahead
good
morning yes sir good morning i would
like to know what mr yang thinks about
the current path that joe biden's taking
us down of socialism and marxism in lieu
of
capitalism thank you
well thank you for the question uh my
outlook on this is that this is a little
bit like the polarization question where
you have two sides and then it seems
like they clash past clash and then when
we come to these economic conversations
it's socialism capitalism clash class
clash the reality is that in america we
have a system that in some ways is way
too
um generous to corporations we have like
a version of corporate socialism and in
many respects
where like if a big company gets into
trouble the government is there to bail
them out you know we saw that certainly
with uh with wall street um not that
long ago uh and so right now we have in
my mind the worst of all worlds where we
have socialism for really rich and
powerful companies and by the way very
very low taxes where you have trillion
dollar companies like amazon paying next
to nothing in taxes so socialism for
mega corps
and then for
uh individuals if you're down on your
lock then it must be something you did
um
and so
uh the the
conversation to me has to be
tweaked to figure out like who we're
talking about and what the goals are um
but i am going to suggest that this
conversation is part of the manipulation
is that the way i can make you upset is
by saying look the other people are
pushing for you know like for for
socialism or whatnot and and then you
have to unpack it's like what do i what
are we really talking about and i'll
give you an example
most people watching this right now
would agree drug prices are too high and
we should get them lower
is that socialism like is it socialism
to have a government negotiate lower
drug prices on behalf of millions and
millions of americans most all of us
think having the government negotiate on
behalf would be sensible i mean why
would you spend extra money on drugs for
people um and so you have to distinguish
uh uh between
um the goals the specific goals you have
and then these big
labels which in my mind sometimes will
end up leading us in the wrong direction
uh mr yang when it comes to presidential
politics uh viewer in arizona says the
first step
should be to change the presidential
debate commission i propose that any
candidate that is on enough state
ballots to mathematically win the
electoral college should automatically
be included in the presidential debates
well this is one sign of the duopoly
really the duopoly has made it nearly
impossible for anyone else to run for
lots of offices around the country and
certainly you could throw a president
into the mix
uh right now the threshold to make a
presidential debate is 15 polling uh
which is extraordinarily high to this
uh person's point and i agree we should
make the criteria more realistic and
achievable to have different points of
view met if your goal is to have
different points of view met
open primaries would be very very
helpful
um we need to open it up and that this
uh locking out of smaller points of view
is but you could say it's the most
agreed to set the presidential level but
in my view it's actually
equally egregious at
every other level
like we're doing it everywhere i think
we should change it everywhere i agree
with that uh another follow-up from
another viewer who just simply asked you
directly if you plan to run for
president
uh i am focused on trying to make our
system work better for us uh and that
actually starts in 2022 like we don't
have any time to waste
memphis tennessee democrats lying this
is ken
yes uh my question is
uh
why do the democrats uh continue to try
to work with joe manchin and christian
cinema when it's obvious is that they uh
stand in the way of progress
don't the 14th amendment give them the
opportunity to expel them or either
to ask them to resign to replace them
with someone that can get progress done
because
uh you know it seems to me that they're
working for lobbyists or working for
someone else and they're not working for
the democracy or the democratic party
uh i'm not aware of an ability for them
to somehow have the them expelled uh you
know the the only accountability i know
of is that the voters in west virginia
and arizona would decide that you know
that they're not uh fans of their their
leadership um and i think that that's
gonna take a little while uh to your
bigger point
um
it is a sign of um
of
the difficulty in my view of having only
two labels where someone spoke to me the
other day and was like hey does it seem
like you know kirsten cinema and
some of the other people are in the same
party
[Laughter]
i i would uh so i i will speak for
myself on this like i would like to see
things get done in washington and
um i hope that
uh
that senator cinema and manchin uh you
know are able to outline what it would
take for them to come to the table and
get something done
from beth in tampa florida independent
line
good morning good morning
thank you for taking my call um
left right wrong right i mean
i watch man i watch the republicans say
their side i watch the democrats say
their side i watch cnn i watch fox
i don't know how anybody knows what to
choose anymore we're all raised with
certain values i'm 58 years old my
father worked three jobs when i was a
child to put food on the table if we're
going to be handing money to people and
not getting them to to get work to
provide for their families that that
doesn't seem to in my point as a
valuable thing to do
but my mind is different than your mind
just like my neighbor's mind is
different my husband's is different than
mine
we've always been that way everybody
thinks differently everybody values
differently who's right who's wrong i
don't even know who to believe when i
watch this stuff on the news because one
says one thing the next group comes up
they say something different completely
opposite you know yes the debt limits
you know we're going to have to do it
but who's going to do it and they fight
like children it's all ridiculous but we
need to work we need old-fashioned
values we need to be responsible and
accountable for our own actions okay
that's beth in tampa florida thank you
oh beth um first you're 100 correct that
no one knows what to believe or think
anymore because we're in these strange
information silos and bubbles
i do think c-span is something of a
counter weight to that
it's one reason why i talk about it so
favorably
i love
work i love jobs i love people having a
place to go where they're going to
interact with other people and do
something
uh that contributes and makes them proud
then they can go home at the end of the
day and feel like they did something for
themselves and their families that's
going to help move everyone in a better
direction uh
the to me the the biggest phenomenon we
should be focused on right now is why
are so few americans working
um
the labor force participation rate is at
multi-decade lows relative to when you
grew up beth and i think you know that i
think we all know that so then you look
around and say okay like how do we get
more people working how do we create
more jobs there are different ways you
could go about it
but i'm going to suggest that if people
have some more money in their pocket
they're going to go to the local
restaurant or business or hardware store
and then that store is going to have to
hire an extra person or two
that to me is something the government
can actually deliver on um in a way that
if i were to say like the government's
going to create jobs in another way
maybe maybe not you know what i mean uh
so i'm 100 with you though uh i i
you know i'm a parent i want my kids to
work hard i like to believe i work hard
um so yeah like uh we're on the same
page uh mr yang a viewer wants to know
your thoughts on abolishing the
electoral college and going to a popular
vote for president
thank you um i i think that this
conversation is uh something that you
can only feel than the abstract and what
do i mean by that if you were to go to
montana or wyoming and say hey how would
you like to completely decrease your
influence of course they would say no
in order to
eliminate the electoral college you
would need a super majority essentially
of states and representatives and no
one's going to do it uh you know like so
talking about it
actually
ends up leading you in a direction where
in my mind it ends up furthering the
divide um that's why it should only be
talked about in the abstract not the
practice unless you can bring senators
from uh wyoming and and montana to the
table and are like yup don't like having
influence
uh now the founding fathers set up the
electoral college for a very legitimate
reason which is that they didn't want
certain more populated areas to dominate
if you were to have a presidential
election where it's just popular vote
someone like me would never set foot in
any rural area we would just go to major
population markets and just try and get
on tv in new york la is that desirable
um so so the entire thing to me is not
something we should be using our head on
unless again like you expect all the
people and representatives of less
populated states to shoot themselves on
the foot which they're not going to do
so yeah like that's where i am you could
talk about it as like you know if you
could do it would you want to do it
that's a different question but it's
never going to happen so we should try
and focus on fixing the system in a way
that we can actually fix you know like
what the forward party what i'm
championing wants to fix things at a
state level where enough of us get
together we can make it happen it's
already happened in in at least one
state like that and it's in our
interests too so
yeah that's where i am let's focus on
real solutions that will help help our
country right now a few more minutes
with our guest becky is in massachusetts
republican line
yes hi i know you're getting to the end
of the show so i'm going to try and be
quick
um
i am a trump supporter and if he went to
the uh
an independent party i would follow him
what i wanted to say is i appreciate the
fact that mr yang is an outsider of
washington and
i think that's wonderful that's what we
need there's too many people that are
two inside washington but my question is
and i'll take it offline is
when you ran for president did you
expect
joe biden to be the winner and kamala
harris to be the vice president
because of politics or
did you not
think that
in in running
was it already predetermined
thank you
oh thank you and thank you for the kind
words uh they mean a lot to me you know
we're all americans we're all parents we
just want the best for our families uh
and i think that there was real
resonance to trump's message
um because people are
sensing that it's not working right it's
not working it's not working now i have
a very different recipe a very different
prescription
like i think that you know we should try
and like fix the the guts of the system
that's breaking
um but thank you you know we're all
americans uh we all should be able to to
um see the
commonality now did i think that joe and
kamala were going to win um
you know i mean when i was running as a
nominee against them
if you remember that time there were
actually very tough times for both joe
and kavala
so
i'm not sure i would have called it at a
certain point in the race after they
became the nominees did i think that
they were going to defeat trump um i i
thought that they i thought that they
would get more votes i did um
and
um i thought that that would happen in
part because you know like i i thought
that
um the the country
um
you know it was struggling at that time
and i thought that people would be
looking for a different approach
us from california in south san
francisco yvonne hello
independent live good morning good man
good morning andrew i'm so excited
you're what you're you're doing this
independent i'm an independent now
because it's just so tired of all the
lies and so i'm excited
to be
to to uh
what are you doing
yay
go ahead caller we're running short on
time with your question or comment
i have no question i'm just happy that
there that that andrew is running for
and i'm and i'm i'm on team
i'll take it i'll take that as a
question or comment forward we're going
to move the country forward
independently tonight
if you are an independent who's sick and
tired of the nonsense join me and let's
clean it up you know just first
principles the founding fathers would be
horrified at what's happened to us it's
going to get worse not better so let's
be positive and fix it and do it in a
way that unifies the country hopefully
you know again we're one country like
we're beautiful people if you get
someone individually down to talk to you
lovely
you know i mean like so what the heck is
happening to us i have talked to you as
you all imagined i have talked to
thousands and thousands of americans of
every background in every environment
rural suburban
uh city
and we can
get along beautifully
if we actually see ourselves as human
beings but we're we're being set up
we're being set up to be at each other's
throats it's not working at all we got
to turn it around so thank you mr yang
what's a measurable amount of success
for your efforts as the forward party is
how would you measure measure success
uh we're going to measure success by how
many states we can unlock from the this
uh partisan primary system
you can have ballot initiatives in up to
24 states we're probably not going to
run that many but hopefully in 22 you're
going to see the process change in some
states around the country and if you'd
like to help make that happen join me at
forwardparty.com we're also going to
support local candidates hopefully we'll
have some of them win too
andrew yang is the head of the ford
party the author of ford notes on the
future of our democracy mr yang thanks
for your time today i'll come back any
time pedro this is so much fun i love
talking to americans have me back
thank you very much uh coming up we're
going to take you to a hearing taking a
look at hurricane ida response uh
testimony from the army corps of
engineers you can follow along there if
you can't sit down and watch you can
always download our free c-span video
app and watch it there as well at c-span
now find it at your app store or at our
website that's it for our program today
another edition of washington journal
come to your way tomorrow morning we'll
see you then